Bobby says he's home and she really
homeless you way to sleeping tonight
I've got no clue I'm okay you ever smoke
Java phone if you if you do whatever it
takes and you find a way I'm going on
that website okay you've got to get you
in second amid another property -
investors got going at UK yeah right
if I see you at that event if you go on
that website you go on that website you
can book on for four you need a credit
card if you can find a credit card and
you can book on do you come for free and
you come along to the event I'll give
you one thousand pound just for coming
to the event you just come on I don't
have video and you can show me that you
can you can like just to me to hold this
to account on Samuel Leeds here I'm just
with my no machine on I'm in this Bobby
Bobby Bobby says he's homeless you
really hung us
you're way stupid tonight I've got no
clue on the street okay if Bobby okay my
words goes to property - investors
doctor at UK you remember the website
yeah if he comes down and arrives on
timing there's a credit card you better
you've got to figure that out you gotta
fit down to get there if he gets there
arrives on time place pull out for two
days
[ __ ] it I won't give you 1,000 pounds
I'll give you 2,000 pounds I'll give you
2,000 pounds no strings attached just
come because I'm confident that if you
can't I'm confident that you'll be able
to knock back and that's me familiar I'm
confident about you go make some money
thank you you got to get the 2000 on so
basically what I just said is I just
taught back but you can ask me 30 pounds
to starve is he's homeless
I said did I'll give you two pounds but
I'll give you 2,000 pounds all I want
you to do is come to the property
investors crash course if you just turn
up and play fallout for two days we're
going to figure out how to get there and
get there on time of doing the website
you can figure out how to get there play
fallout for two days
I'll give you no strings
2,000 pound cash he says is homeless as
a complete give away gift so let's see
let's see if he's good freeze where that
see if he turns up if it turns up all
enjoy giving in the 2,000 pounds why
will I give him 2,000 pounds because I
freaking know that if he comes I know
that he won't have to be homeless
anymore
because on the crash course I'm so
confident that he will learn the skills
to go start making money because anyone
can do this I just have everyone show up
I hope he shows up I tell what if you do
show up I'll give him to you I enjoy
giving him 2,000 pounds he won't even
care about the 2,000 pounds once he's
shown up because of the knowledge that
he learns that he won't be homeless
anymore that's for sure you know what if
he turns up I'm gonna give him 2,000
pound and then I'm gonna bother with him
or I'll find someone else I'm gonna do
financial freedom challenge of a
homeless person what do you reckon
Amelia yeah find a homeless person do
the financial freedom challenge with
them because I'm just I'm just so
confident and I'm just pissed off people
always asking me so much I'm happy to
give people money no problem but give
somebody that's going to do is they're
gonna be the same situation in the next
hour or the next day and they're gonna
become dependent and I want people to be
financially free and independent so see
what happens what do you reckon
directing bogging will show up comment
below thoughts
[Music]
[Music]
you